how silly of me thank snow white snow
white princess hey snow white as the
first Disney Princess you had a lot of
pressure to be perfect
animators spent a lot of time redrawing
you we can't believe you were almost a
blonde but their hard work paid off
you became the first in a long line of
awesome female Disney characters but we
know that they couldn't make you too
perfect there's a reason your head is so
much bigger than the other princesses a
lot of factors go into designing Disney
characters we have the truth behind the
iconic looks of ten of your favorite
princesses keep watching to find out why
Snow White has such a big head and only
then will I return your satchel to you
that is my deal rapunzel rapunzel is one
of the newest Disney Princesses she's
also one of the most popular design
Rapunzel was no easy task after all her
hair is magical and a crazy long she was
the first computer-generated princess so
she needed to stand out they wanted to
make her very realistic so they kept her
face from being perfectly symmetrical
and they also gave her big front teeth
the animators said that the key to
beauty is strangeness we definitely love
that idea
Belle we can't imagine Belle from Beauty
and the Beast and anything other than
her gold gown or blue dress but her ball
gown was originally pink the designers
changed it so she would look different
from Princess Aurora Belle's blue dress
is that color for a reason she's
supposed to stand out from the villagers
if you watched the original movie again
you'll see that the other villagers wear
shades of orange brown and beige the
animators also gave Belle a wisp of hair
that won't stay back so she wouldn't
look too perfect cuz if you tell a wish
it won't come true
Cinderella after the success of Snow
White Disney waited over a decade before
they released another princess movie
Disney wanted to make Cinderella perfect
by society standards she was supposed to
be the kind of girl that girls want to
be and boys want to date the studio
researched what was perfect for the time
that's why they made Cinderella blond
medium height and 120 pounds apparently
blonde was seen as the best color
in love times have definitely changed
[Music]
Jasmine did you know that jasmine was
named after a famous actress in the
1990s Jasmine guy was a popular star who
made the name jasmine popular Disney
originally tried to make Princess
Jasmine look like Jasmine guy but her
looks just didn't match the animation
style of Aladdin so the lead animator
Mark n used an old high school yearbook
photo of his sister they were also going
to make her outfit pink to sell more
toys but they decided to keep her blue
to symbolize water very funny so what
now I reckon you wanna kiss tiana talk
about pressure when Disney began working
on The Princess and the Frog they had to
make sure Tiana was perfect as the first
black princess they didn't want to mess
up and offend people so they decided to
base every detail off of one real person
anika Noni Rose was the voice actress
who played Tiana even the dimples are
the same they also gave Tiana way more
outfits than other princesses 11 to be
exact
they did that entirely for marketing
purposes to sell more toys after the
first two princesses Disney was ready to
make another one they spent five years
designing Sleeping Beauty and Princess
Aurora Aurora is different from the
other princesses because her features
are very sharp and angular this is
because the background settings were
designed by Eyvind Earle he made a
beautiful fairytale world but if Aurora
had softer features she would have
looked out of place they made her look
less rigid by giving her violet eyes
Pocahontas in the 1990s Disney started
making their princesses more diverse the
character Pocahontas was inspired by a
real-life historical figure the
animators wanted to base their princess
to look like the real one but then they
saw pictures of the real Pocahontas
there are several drawings and paintings
of the real woman
they decided she wasn't quite up to the
standards of a Disney princess they made
some adjustments and for some reason
added some Asian facial features to her
like a man doesn't mean I have to smell
like one Mulan Mulan spends a good chunk
of the movie in disguise as a man this
was a challenge for the animators they
wanted her to look boyish so she doesn't
have the exaggerated eyes and lips of
the other princesses but she couldn't
look too boyish this is by her face
changes throughout the movie when she is
in disguised as a boy her eyelashes go
away her eyebrows become thicker when
she is dressed as a girl the features go
back to normal why Aaron run away with
you Arielle we can't imagine the
original Ariel as anything other than a
redhead as the first redheaded princess
lots of little girls who loved her but
did you know she was almost a blonde the
studio went with red for two big reasons
first of all another studio released a
live-action mermaid movie called splash
it had a blonde mermaid so they didn't
want to rip off the look second blonde
hair was harder to darken for the
underwater scenes they went with red and
it was a huge hit no white Snow White is
another princess who almost turned up
blonde the original fairytale described
Snow White is having skin as white as
snow lips as red as blood and hair as
black as ebony but Disney had her as a
blonde for a while they changed it back
to black to be more relatable
Snow White also has a huge head this is
to make her look more proportional to
the Seven Dwarves
she lives with which Disney Princess has
your favorite look let us know in the
comments thanks for watching for more
awesome videos about all things Disney
hit that subscribe button and don't
forget to give us a big thumbs up we'll
see you next time
[Music]